[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mark stein covers the nba for the new
york times he's been covering the nba
since 1994
and i wanted to have him on because he
gave me
well the headline writer at the new york
times gave me the headline the nba's 500
million dollar hope for the holidays
as we're not sure when the season is
going to start and mark kind enough to
join us
so what's at stake here what's in play
for this decision and when do you think
this decision happens mark
i think we're going to get it this week
and i think we're going to get
the pre-christmas start there obviously
naturally few teams
that don't want to start that quick with
the lakers at the top of the list
but because the nba has
been trying to convince the players that
at least 500 million is at stake if
the start isn't closer to christmas and
i think they're succeeding
in that effort you know that
that revenue that's at stake is what's
going to drive this thing and what's
going to get the season
started way sooner than any of us
thought when we were in the bubble
in the bubble people were saying it
could be february it could be march but
i i think we will find out this week
that it is
it is starting christmas week but if i
look at the rank and file i don't know
does this come down to a vote mark how
do they decide if they're going to play
december 22nd or they're going to play
january 13th
theoretically it comes down to a vote
but as we saw
before the restart if form holds
the union will just have player reps
vote that's the way they did it when
they decided
to restart the season unless the union
unexpectedly breaks form it's going to
be a vote of 30 player reps as opposed
to
450 players so basically player rep
union officials and player reps they're
spending this week
you know talking to players kind of
giving them a chance to voice their
opposition but
more and more i hear that that i think
players understand that with this kind
of money on the line
how much money they would lose waiting
until january
it would be a shock if it's not
christmas week so i
i think i think we're going to get the
it's going to be crazy nba draft on this
on november 18th free agency is going to
be
48 to 72 hours it will start that quick
after the draft
and by december 1 teams are going to be
in training camp well
what if lebron says i don't want to play
the first month
that would be that would be look if
anybody has the juice to pull that off
it's him
i don't want to jump in his head and try
to predict it i mean
you know he i think if you really study
it he
voiced opposition initially to
i'm not playing with if there's no fans
and he changed his position on that
he initially was you know it
in late august after the bucks staged
their walk out of a playoff game
you know lebron he said it the other
night on hbo he
he he gave serious thought to ending his
bubble
time right there and changed his mind
then
and you know with time will he say you
know what i'm going to play on christmas
only he knows but
that alone will not i don't think lebron
alone could stop
this season from starting on christmas i
i just feel like there's too much
momentum behind it now are we looking at
regionalized bubbles are we done with
bubbles completely for this upcoming
scenario
we're not we're we're gonna see it's
gonna be it's everything you just talked
about the nfl i think the nba is gonna
be
dealing with the same thing they nobody
wants to do bubbles again
teams want to play in their home markets
so i think what we're going to see again
nothing is
nothing is firm yet but i think what
we're going to see is
teams in their home markets and
the coronavirus will start to infiltrate
the nba like baseball had to deal with
like the nfl is dealing with now like
so many top teams in international
soccer are dealing with i don't
i don't think there's any way around it
if teams want to play in their markets
but
the appetite for doing the bubble again
is pretty close to zero
um james harden available
ca on the market no not yet
teams are monitoring for sure teams are
curious
because you know all indications were
that the two candidates that
james harden would have supported the
most would have been either
ty lue who went to the clippers or john
lucas who's been
on mike d'antoni staff the past four
seasons and is really popular
in that houston locker room obviously
neither of those guys got the job in
houston i think houston made
a good choice in very difficult
circumstances steven silas is
as highly regarded as an assistant coach
can be in this league he's been at it
for
two decades well regarded for his
offensive mind and everywhere he's been
just incredibly well-liked just one of
the most well-liked people
in the nba so to walk into that
situation which
i mean there's tension mike d'antoni
walked away daryl mori walked away
the rockets have little flexibility to
change their team they have a new gm and
rafael stone and now steve and silas
have to walk in there
and get james harden on board that's not
going to be easy
but if go ahead if you follow him he's
proven an ability to do that wherever
he's been
i'll let you go with this it feels like
people are sleeping on the golden state
warriors
that steph coming back clay coming back
you still have draymond you got a high
draft pick here
or am i missing out on something because
when we talk about title contenders
yeah i i would have thought golden state
would be right there with the lakers
look people don't want to say it but
i'll say it i mean the lakers hey they
took advantage
but the league was down this year i mean
it was
it did it was a it was it was a factor
in there i mean they obviously have
the best duo in the league lebron and
anthony davis they are the number one
duo in the league
and no one can touch that but the
supporting cast was spotty
yeah and the competition level just
wasn't
it wasn't at the level that we've seen
over the past five years that helped him
i look the warriors need
size and athleticism they do i mean
you gotta have that to counter anthony
davis but
you know i'll take my chances with steph
curry clay thompson coming off so much
rest draymond green coming back
let's see what they can do with wiggins
they've got some some trade assets to
upgrade the roster i
i totally agree with you is there a hot
draft pick because it feels like nobody
wants to be drafting
up high no i mean the reality is this
draft there is there
you know there is not a difference maker
and look it's going to be way too
soon to know these kids come in so young
now
that there are always surprises
you know you know donovan mitchell is a
classic case of a few years ago
you know he's you know he's nowhere near
the number one pick and look at the
difference maker he
he became i mean so there there there's
always the potential for surprise but
yeah at the top of this draft there's a
lot of uncertainty
and you know minnesota and golden state
they hold the top two picks and no one
will be surprised if either one trades
out of it
who's my guy denny avidia
i hate to say i'm fall i'm falling in
like with him i don't want to fall in
love but
um it's a lot of fun maybe this is luka
doncic spillover
mark but no no no no no don't do that to
the kid that's too much
don't put that don't put that on he
looks
good he looks he's an interesting player
interesting player here's the thing
when you and i were young this league
was teaming with wing players
and every nba team had them and now they
don't
and so that's why i think abdi is an in
you know he's
he's a guy who's going to be able to
play multiple positions
and he does have he does have great
potential and he's
he he will not go lower than six or
seven i mean
he's probably gonna go in that three to
six range
but the doncic comparisons don't help
them because
he's he's not going to have that kind of
impact right off the bat that's just too
much to ask
and uh lamello ball is he still hanging
in there as
the number one pick
i would love to tell you i'm smart
enough to tell you who will be the
number one pick
on november 18th but i am not all right
i am not
that's fine but i i don't know the only
thing i've heard is that he's not good
in interviews
i don't pay much talking to that i mean
but the much bigger concern is
you know his shooting i mean this is you
know
shot creators and wings who can play
multiple positions that's what teams
want
you know guys who can make an impact
with the ball and certainly
you know lamelo has the potential to run
a team
flashy passing he's got all that
size but can he shoot it i mean why the
hell is it that his dad's this
basketball self-proclaimed basketball
genius
but he's got two kids that can't shoot
i mean the same thing you know look my
my whole
my whole family's from israel i mean i'm
i'm i'm i'm right there with you in the
abdia fan club
why is he a sub 60 free throw shooter
why is shooting so hard
i it shouldn't be that should be the
first thing
you master but it you know we continue
to
you know it's there is such a premium on
shooting i and look at what
look at where duncan robinson came from
to where he ended up now because he is
an elite shooter
i would be practicing that more than
anything yeah thank you mark we
appreciate your time as always
sounds good guys that's mark stein
covers the nba for the new york times